I was told that you spoke to Muhammad
Ali on the phone when you were 14 years
old before you were really fight you
know before you were professionally
fighting yeah - you too - yeah well how
did that come about well you know um my
adoptive father momento custom motto
very closely and their birthdays on the
same day January 17th and every day they
called each other to talk crap when
their birthday you know the arrogant
Capricorn so you know a cap coin never
wrong right hey so I would call Ali and
get him on the phone I'll call him and
some no but a lot of famous old-time
fighters call cars and when they call
them I'm on the other phone foot and I
listen to a conversation you creep yes
you know I'm in a house where I'm
hopeful I'm up one day I want to be a
champion fighter and I mighty that means
I have a call and sure but um he would
never let me talk to him so I sneak and
hang on the phone he didn't hear - was I
you can't hear me get on a phone out
here I'm talking to be a bee all these
great fighters and Mickey Walker nothing
either guys I'm reading about oh yeah
and so I talked Ali and Ali had just
lost to Larry Holmes he just lost Larry
Holmes fight at night next morning they
talked they were talking on the phone
and cos this man's a Lawson and then
after all of a sudden if they hold it I
got a 14 year old kid black kid he'll be
champ of the world coming to listen to
me okay there's some listen to me it's
okay and so he put me on the phone he
was saying he never told me to listen to
cuz you have told me why he lost he took
medicine I got weak and he's gonna come
back home God but I'm crying wait big
i'ma get them for you you you told Holly
that you would get homes when I get big
not when I'm a champion when I'm gonna
top fighter when I get bigger I'm only
14 but when I get big I'm I'm a DI ck
head and I'm saying I get big I'm gonna
get them for you you know and then I did
get them but you did get him yeah I mean
that's later on what's craziest you said
that to Muhammad Ali and then a couple
years later you fight Larry Holmes
well wasn't a couple of years later with
six years later yeah okay six years
later you fight
my mistake but you fight Larry Holmes
and what happens well I happened I was
very lucky to win now he was pretty old
at that time like Holmes like Ali was
old when he fought Holmes yeah he's
pretty old and 38 and I was 20 mm-hmm
and I won you won and Muhammad Ali was
at that fight yes he was here and what
did Muhammad Ali say to you well you
think get him for me and you were like I
got that I can take care of that